thank you
[Music]
guys might have heard about this but
these kids in Bangladesh are playing
hide and seek one of them decides to
hide inside of a shipping container
that's just crazy and he falls asleep
he's in America his friends don't find
him and he wakes up uh in Malaysia oh
[__] yeah six six uh days later that is
[__] crazy he's the best personality
ever six days he accidentally like locks
himself in yeah he goes in and then
shuts the thing six days so he didn't
have food water so he won though he won
right he's the best hide and seek person
ever yeah this is kind of cool
kind of cozy in here
oh my God and so when they found him he
didn't die they end up finding him at
the port and then they thought he was a
child trafficking victim that's so funny
yeah no I was playing a game
[Laughter]
you ever take a nap and wake up in
another country
that's what happened I don't know where
I am God this is like Life of Pi oh my
God yeah that's literally life of pie it
is literally yeah Richard Parker yeah
they find him uh yeah six days aft
without food or water how do you do that
I can't eat that for two hours you must
have slept the whole time and they were
able to yeah they found him he's
malnourished just like that was six days
in the dark too that's scary you think
he was drinking or opening up packages
hopefully maybe there was something in
there he was already skinny as [__] as
it is man Bangladesh kid playing in a
[__] Shipyard yeah this is like some
poverty fun dude yeah I got this old
yeah it's rough hey this will put me on
the show what's it called the alone oh
yeah alone I love that show that show
really shows who's like a [__] or not
dude really what is it about you would
like it alone so they send out all these
people out into these different parts of
the world survival last person that
survives that doesn't call it in to go
home is the one that wins so it can go
up to a [__] year and it's always
it's always right before winter so about
like the 50-day Mark or something like
that that's when it starts to get like
snow and stuff the the lake that they're
fishing at freezes over so they can't
get the fish anymore and there's bears
everywhere yeah watching people lose
their sanity is so satisfying oh yeah
this is guy I I love this episode it's
like one of them die no no no no no
they'll pull them out before you have a
lot of coffee and then there's also
health checks they give them equipment
so you're like a vlogger yeah they have
to film themselves the whole time whoa
what if you suck at cinematography then
you get you're out yeah you don't get
that much air time
alone though so you really have nothing
to do butt film yourself exactly and
they were talking about this is one guy
that had me dying laughing because he's
you know he's like one of the white
dudes with the dreads and everything and
literally on a log staring out to the
lake and he just out of nowhere just
goes done
I'm like
why because he's losing it people go
crazy when they're by themselves
one of the person said uh this is a girl
who left she says something very
profound what I didn't think about she
says the camera for the vlogging purpose
is actually to help you with your sanity
but she says I think it makes it worse
because you're just sitting there
talking to yourself and all your deep
inner thoughts and secrets come out and
you start telling it to this camera
because they're not talking back so you
just tell them everything you start
losing your mind
which is what they love yeah it's the
best except for Ratings this one of the
best shows really some of the seasons
suck there's like 12 Seasons or nine
season now some of them are like okay
but some are really freaking good I saw
seasonal and in the very beginning I
feel like it's like very reality TV so
it's just a TV so they just take random
people that obviously can't last but
then once people realize because it's
like you 100 000 or whatever right once
people realize what this is now you
start getting like the gangsters coming
out people that are like I'm a
survivalist yeah my whole life I've been
living in the woods or like I'm a
[__] like Delta Marine or whatever
the [__] that's going on and then you
start having mad badasses come out that
know how to do all these crazy things
and the like the houses that they build
for themselves are so [__] cool but
then some of them are like all right
you're not gonna make it my boy 100 yeah
so this guy's making a [__] Log Cabin
bro hey homie who [__] caught the
moose and it was too lean so you're
still losing too much you guys see that
one yeah even though he was eating it it
wasn't giving a nourishment the first
like four seasons it's like that's how
it is for any type of show because
you're getting the people that would
applied it that they don't even know
this is gonna be a successful show yeah
that's why you always see second third
fourth fifth season gets crazier yeah so
like there are certain people too where
you see them like build like primitive
survival you know that channel that we
watch where they build like Huts for
real though and in the first season this
person just like I'm trying to learn how
to do this not and then they tie it up
and it just crumbs and then just
watching them the whole [__] thing
catches on fire yeah yeah oh those are
the best parts do they are they given
any tools do you get 10 items so let's
choose so they have like a list and you
get to choose 10 of them so some people
grab like a bow and arrow some people
grab like the fire starter some people
grab like paracord or whatever it is but
everybody gets the same list that you
get to choose from and from there like
their strategy and [__] all you have is
your nudity and then two tools yeah that
you get to choose yeah that was crazy
yeah but they're not there for an
extended period of time it's only you
know the 21 days and then you get
airlifted off this is whoever is the
last person to survive wins so you can
go as long as yeah and the last two
people too you'll never know you don't
know if there's like five people or like
whatever if you're the last two people
you just wait and then it's not until
when the second to last person Taps out
and you're the winner that they bring
your like significant other to surprise
you yourself oh that's crazy that's when
you see people that drop into tears oh
hell yeah it's such a good show because
like you'll think like oh this
[__] has been killing it he got
food he made a shelter and then he he
digs up this dirt root and he's like oh
this is good for like cleansing health
or whatever the [__] he eats it and then
just poisoning goes crazy bro just
completely [__] this is one episode
yes this girl was killing it doing it
fine she's talking to camera like you
know
she almost chops off yeah
you were doing so well and then she
couldn't fix that she had to get a
little bit awesome stupid [__]
infections and exactly so you never
[__] know and then I watched this
cooking show right after where this guy
was crying because he didn't seen this
family for two days [__]
context did you guys ever see that that
old school Japanese streamed uh show
seppuku from like it was from like the
90s it was like one of the first 24 hour
stream things where they got a guy and
he agreed to be alone in a in a room and
he his job was to survive only on things
that he could win through sweepstakes oh
so they would he would have to enter
sweepstakes all day low how does he know
what sweepstakes are available they're
giving him all the things that he that
he needs to he just has to keep
submitting to do yeah
[Laughter]
yeah but the goal is they the goal is
that they'll release him once he earns a
hundred thousand dollars worth of items
so he so sometimes he would win stuff
that he can't use like he would get like
a PlayStation game or like something and
no TV and no stuff but then as it went
on like it got kind of like super
popular because this was just on online
way like old school internet days people
found out where he lived they had to
move him and then um and then they
[__] with him they acted like he made
it and they took him out and they
brought him to Korea and they let him
have a day in the amusement park by
himself and this dude's his hair is all
overgrown fear and everything he thought
he was celebrating and instead they made
him do it again but in Korea and in
Korean no
and then he falls in hot water and then
this time yeah my favorite one of all
time dude and this time they were like
all right now you have to do it again in
Korea and you have to write in Korean
plus you have to make enough for a first
class ticket back home to Japan wow and
he got so good at it that he was able to
do it even quicker and by the time he
got moved back uh to Japan they put him
in another room and the sickest thing
they already knew that he had made it
they put him in this room he thought it
was just another day and then the walls
[__] fall down and he's on stage
thousands of people and they're all like
yeah
jacking off
she had no clothes on yeah that is the
one he was naked dude you guys have to
watch the whole it's crazy I have to
watch it it's crazy I need to find that
thing yeah this TV show is a [__]
nightmare
it was an 18-month live stream of
non-stop I yeah it was it it ended up
going 18 months yeah dude Japanese
people don't care about mental health at
all
that's what I love about them so much
when I see them put somebody through an
elevator and it just collapses
underneath
it's amazing
event of the [__] ring girl just
comes out of the bathroom
yeah this guy's name is tomoaki uh wait
no sorry it's a nasubi and he's he was a
comedian and now like so he went through
this whole [__] now he's in an asylum
well no he became a he became a uh like
a consultant for how people were gonna
survive the pandemic being alone so long
wow extra strong in his brain dude look
at this photo this book is hilarious Yo
he was alone that whole time was it
Jordan peels that's what I thought I
thought he was Jordan
his eyebrows are [__] nuts
I know that that means like he looks
like Jordan peel when he does a
character on the team when he's the
football player yeah yeah dude four
fours dude he's got some sick ass
eyebrows